c'est un cabaret pas comme les autres
qui s'est installée il ya dix ans un
grès à la périphérie d'orléans un
cabaret moderne de 220 places qui
bouscule les codes traditionnels
ici les plumes sont tribales et les
seins de se dénude que si le spectacle
je justifie
[Musique]
l'instigateur de ce concept c'est
laurent des caves orléanais d'origine
issu du monde de l'audiovisuel
il est revenu s'installer sur ses terres
avec sa femme chanteuse avec cette idée
bien précise de monter un spectacle mais
pas n'importe lequel
là ça vraiment faire pile un siècle en
2018 que le monde du vin que le style
cabaret a été inventé il n'a pas bougé
alors beaucoup se targue de ça en disant
c'est bien parce que ça veut dire qu'on
a des on a des valeurs
c'est des choses traditionnelles et est
ce que je réponds à cela c'est que si on
écoutait la même musique depuis un
siècle
enfin aujourd'hui on serait pas très
satisfait de ce à quoi donc c'est pas un
cabaret de demain c'est le cabaret
d'aujourd'hui donc là il ya un joli
programme pour aujourd'hui et notamment
dans dix minutes on va devoir faire des
reprises et
des répétitions sur de la vidéo lors des
répétitions
laurent des caves n'est jamais très loin
du chorégraphe maxime courilleau et
c'est normal le patron du voulez-vous
est aussi l'auteur et le metteur en
scène du spectacle prophétie qui se joue
depuis le mois d'octobre
on essaye de travailler sur une synergie
entre le vivant et le virtuel et bill
virtuel évidemment il existe grâce à la
vidéo j'essaye de ne pas me poser de
codes et de limites
donc je fais ce que j'ai envie de voir
en fait voilà c'est aussi peut-être que
ça j'écris les spectacles que j'ai envie
de voir le show façon cabaret moderne
fonctionne bien
à tel point que le voulez vous fait des
petits un autre établissement a ouvert à
côté de lyon le spectacle est différent
mais on y retrouve les fans diplôme
[Musique]